hello everyone and welcome to the
corridor cast
today's guest is Lou Ferrigno jr. you
may recognize him from the series that
we did Battlefield rush or he's on TV in
SWAT playing one of the SWAT guys which
is pretty cool he's also on 911 a couple
other TV shows as well Lou Ferrigno jr.
has a unique name you may recognize the
name because his father was the
Incredible Hulk so Lou has a lot of
really interesting stories to tell us
such as getting out there trying to make
it in LA coming from a background of
having a celebrity father how do you
claim a name for yourself when there's
so much pop culture around it already a
lot of really interesting stuff and I do
want to mention this cozy sweatshirt I'm
wearing well this podcast is brought to
you by this cozy sweatshirt because this
cozy sweatshirt is new in the corridor
store that's right corridor dot corridor
digital calm slash door anyways corridor
digital that's dot-com dot store oh boy
it's crazy I don't know the URL to my
own store apparently I'm getting all
flustered doing this podcast intro
alright corridor digital dot store
that's where you go alright enough of
that push let's listen to what the cool
stories Lou has to tell us hey Lou
thanks for joining us today on the
corridor cast podcast you happy to be
here yeah I love the blazer man thank
you you know I buy all these nice
clothes for auditions and and stuff or
even just to be this guy and I never
wear them so I'm like screw it I'm gonna
start putting things together and be
that guy there you go you know it's nice
to know that you hold our podcast at
such a high esteem that you'll dress up
for it even though a lot of people just
listen to it
no I watch it I watched your podcast
oh is that crazy that's that's not crazy
at all okay someone out in these days
people think watching podcasts that you
watch but I'm like yeah they're actually
great you know I got the nuances and the
subtle like idiosyncrasies of people
yeah that's awesome so for those of you
who aren't familiar Lou here you was in
the the battlefield series of a shot
three month three years ago called rush
but since then you've gone undo quite a
bunch of really interesting things there
currently I want once you run down your
project list with me real quick here
okay how how crazy things have actually
gotten things have been great for the
last year and a half I've been shooting
a show called SWAT on CBS
it's a SWAT show it's a one-hour drama
which is going fantastic when our second
season hopefully we get picked up for a
third I just got done with shooting a
second episode of 9-1-1 which I'm
playing a firefighter and that one the
table and then I'm doing starred role on
its a DC WB show where I play a
superhero beginning in March that sounds
really cool no that's he sounds really
busy
it's been really good but I mean SWAT
I'll tell you doing SWAT it's a it was
so nice going into SWAT with such great
prior knowledge from all the work we did
and on tactical stuff with rush and a
lot of that was to your credit cuz it
was really good to know and you taught
it and well in slow is smooth smooth
this fella that was I was spitting it
out as they were teaching us and I was
one of the only guys who knew what was
going on you know in a room I mean and
even the the other one we did I was like
that was it was it was such a nice setup
for what's happening now so thank you
Jake yeah happy to help
yeah for sure yeah I said it now there
is one thing you said to me in Detroit
when were filming rush that really stuck
with me I think it was like we were only
a couple days into filming so I'd only
known you for a couple days at that
point and we were talking about about
your name you know Lou Ferrigno jr. and
you had mentioned something to me that
really stuck with me and I still think
about it every once in a while these
days and you're talking about how you
want you had this drive to go out there
and make the name your own you know your
father's obviously a pretty big figure
in in film he's played a lot of rather
pivotal characters you know Hercules the
Hulk etc but you had to strive to go out
there and to find yourself as Lou
Ferrigno as Lou Ferrigno so and when
somebody says they're very know they're
speaking about you and that really stuck
out with me because that's really I
think admirable quality a really cool
drive to have to make your name yours
and that was really really neat but I'm
curious like what are what are some of
the advantages to having the name lou
ferrigno versus what are some of the
disadvantages well for me personally
honestly is when someone comes up to me
and they see the name and like a light
shines in their eyes and they're at
glowing and market or when I'm on the
phone with someone like in another state
you know like a Wells Fargo type of
thing and it just gives him such joy
that's what's really great and I'm like
that and that's what really drove me to
do what I do today is because I'm like
my father has had such an impact by
playing that character the way he did in
these people in people's lives and they
and they don't know how or why but I
think when people really feel something
they tell you that's real and you don't
say things to make you feel good you
know and my whole life people would
either recognize my name and tell their
story of how they were scared to death
on Friday nights and it just impacted
him in such a positive way that's a big
positive for me and then on the other
side the one of a lot of the negatives
are people making their their
presumptions about you as a person about
your talent about your work ethic you
know lumping you into another category
of celebrity kids you know I never felt
that way but there's but that's all
other people and I got to a point in my
life where I'm like I can't affect what
people think I just need to show them
what I can do and and let my work speak
for itself do you think do you think
having the name Lou Ferrigno gets you
into the you know casting offices and
okay so I mean it's hard to say I mean I
think it's definitely interesting to see
if if Lou Ferrigno's a son you know
let's see what he looks like let's see
what he sounds like let's see cuz at the
time when I was first starting out
edition nobody knew who I was
and I think that it can have you know if
I get in trouble legally knock on wood
people are gonna know it just based on
the name you know that big of a kind of
a splash will be made just because of my
name and my affiliation with my father
so that's definitely a negative to it
but I'd you know that's why I stay
on nice like straight and narrow path
for the most part you know like I try to
do good I tried to I'm grateful for what
I have and what my father and my mother
especially has given to me and provided
me with my entire life and support so
it'll always be an answer or question
that I'll have to address but I address
it with gratitude and I address it with
being I'm just very thankful for what I
have now because I've really worked hard
at something that's a craft and I found
that and I can lose myself in that and
instead of blame people for this or
expect this or entitlements a big deal
you know with with a lot of people
unfortunately and there's nothing more
more unappealing I think then someone
who's just really entitled and believes
that they deserve something that they
haven't worked for mm-hmm you know so
yeah I think it's a really healthy
mindset like what are you doing to go
out there and conquer the world so to
speak what are you doing to make it make
it yours I do my dishes every day like I
do anything Nico I every little thing I
just work on moving forward and and
doing I paint and I paint every edge I
paint it's like Steve Jobs with the back
end of the cabinet in his book you know
everything has to be addressed so I stay
balanced in as much as I can in all
facets of life physically spiritually
mentally through work I mean I it's
everyday and it's a crazy business you
never know but I stay truthful myself
and I do my best to really live a
positive healthy lifestyle is that
discipline get exhausting at all very
much so all the time
I got to a point in my life where I was
like cuz I'll die like me they're gonna
make me take my shirt off at any turn
right my guy so someone I know that I
can be shredded if I wanted to be
shredded right but it would take a lot
it would take a lot of eating what I
don't eat eating a lot of what I don't
want to eat when I don't want to eat it
do working hard keeping in line but if
someone's gonna pay that guy to be that
have that physique and be
this on our project and I was like I can
do them I need to do the most I can do
to be that guy hmm
so I really started taking a turn and
being more serious with how I was eating
and really taking everything else a
little bit more seriously with myself
tapes which star girl ended up being a
self tape hmm and just taking everything
just hitting it harder cuz I'm like if I
go down I'm gonna go down burning you
know in flames cuz I'm like it said I'm
running on hope as an actor you know you
don't there's nothing guaranteed so I
just try to do everything in my life as
well as I can do it whatever it may be I
think there's a common thread I've seen
with a lot of body builders and Jake
maybe you've observed this too which is
people who have a good physique
I think people usually associate
somebody you know being traded with
somebody who's like aggressive and
that's really never the case in my
experience in fact it's discipline that
I I see is like the most common trait
with anybody who's in a really good
physical shape it comes from like this
calm discipline and I see it in you as
well
now you've been you've been pretty
involved in the bodybuilding side of I
guess or the bodybuilding world you know
kind of there's like a an event that you
are hosting I don't know if you still
host it now would you like is that a
common trait that you see amongst like
other bodybuilders like this so it's
like sends a discipline or like I guess
the question is rather what does it take
to drive yourself to that point to be on
these schedules and be on this regimen
like how do you where do you find that
energy from well it it really comes down
to if you scrape all the like excess
dead skin away it comes down to really
knowing who you are and knowing what you
need hmm
to get to where you need to go and then
that's really what it comes down to if
you I know that I need did to eat before
this podcast or also I get really [ __ ]
I just don't know but I don't start
thinking right and I'm not as positive
and I'm not as I just you know I need to
be I have to have any kind of food in my
system didn't did it take you years to
learn that or did it um it just got I
got to the point where I can't where you
can't rely on people I can't rely on
people to be to have things ready for me
and usually as I started working because
as you work on set like as an actor just
be prepared to be hungry and
be prepared to be bored because I'm
sitting there on and you know on set and
I'm not I don't have anything with me
I'm in a bad mood and finally I'm like
as long as I have food and I have
something to do and something to put my
time into I'm like I could be here all
day
I love set I love I love every moment on
set I love the random conversations the
interactions the stuff that we talk
about all the time and you never know
who you're gonna meet
as long as I'm fed I'm I can go all day
I'm good huh but it comes down to really
knowing who you are and then the
discipline I mean its consistency with
anything it's what you choose and where
you want to be and the consistency and
the steps it takes to get there with
anything in life you know you have to be
consistent so what's it like on the day
of a big big show like SWAT what's the
day in day in day to day I like it um
it's great I mean it's awesome man it's
uh we got 23 episodes and every other I
mean everybody else is a regular I'm a
guest star so on that episode it's it
could be on location at some awesome
locations like one time our base camp is
right here in Chinatown and we got
shuttled over to some Firestone factory
I guess something different but these
massive massive locations I had no idea
what it was like there's an armored they
got everything set up and like yeah I
just I think about like geeking out man
it's like Oh
flash bang BAM in the pucks like put the
puck on explosions and then you have a
split like a pyro guy come in and he has
this thing and and the budgets great and
the show's awesome and it's like it's
it's really exciting for me now I'm like
you know as a kid I was loving all this
stuff so that I'm like a grown-up kid
now there's other people it's not really
in there like in their wheelhouse you
know but for me it works long as you get
a book and some food yeah dude I mean
I'm just I stay rice cakes helped a lot
you know just keeping something in there
and it's really the act of just keeping
myself say she ate it so it's not like
cuz then I lose myself right yeah what
what goes into getting a a seam finish
for like it's for SWAT like how does it
start and then how does it end like what
happens in between those a lot of people
you know they see the finished product
on TV it's you know some guy talks cut
some other guy talks in scene wraps up
and that's the end like how does that
happen
so there's ABC Camera 3 camera I mean
there's a and B and then this Steadicam
right and that's always going I mean you
got a three camera operators you've got
three assistants you got I mean all
people moving all the time a lot of
moving masters a lot a lot of shots just
like Rach to this person or pan up to
this like blood of these splicing shots
a lot of times joke we joke about it
because it's cycle spins one day we
spent MacArthur Park for like 12 hours
and it was like a minute and a half of
the show walking around running around
and so you never know what's gonna make
it but every directors for the most part
each director has a couple episodes
they've done but it's it was a different
rotation so between having a different
writer and a different director it's
it's challenging to really it's you know
it's fun I love it like I you know i
actor it's like there's a lot I can't
imagine producing it because there's
just a lot of heads there's a lot of
money involved there's a lot of
decisions to be made and then with
everything set up perfectly and then
someone's an hour and a half late to set
although it's like you know what I'm
saying like there's like oh god but I'm
sitting there with my rice cakes I'm on
time I'm good but things happen so but I
mean you'll have the master we'll start
with the master four or five takes of
that and then basically we punch in a
coverage a lot of scenes surprisingly
some scenes take longer than others but
I mean a lot of the scenes that we do or
at the eagle's nest around a big kind of
a desks like this and we're talking but
it's every scene is about I'd say up to
four hours it would take do you get many
shots that I take or it's a kind of a
one-and-done thing I'd say no I'd say no
more than six seven and no less than
three okay
now I'm curious too because you know TV
shows TV shows rotate directors but they
obviously are keeping the same actors
for the characters for every episode so
what what does a new director bring to
the table when they come in like when
you shooting one episode with one at
director and then you shoot another
episode of another director like you're
playing obviously a consistent character
so they can't really step in and like
change who your character is
so how does that relationship work like
what kind of director bring to the table
when there
new director on an audio stylist show I
think some some directors like to push
different shots like we had won one of
the Christmas episode the director I did
not work with him but it was like a
4-minute it was a one-shot there's no
whole thing just like from person from
it was like and then we'll it just it
was a beautiful shot then it ended up in
a crane so they had to hook it back on
the crane and just that shot was a risk
and he took that shot he took that risk
and it played beautifully although I
don't think many people will look at
that and be like oh my goodness that was
a one shot you know it was like a
long-ass Warner
I think attitude is huge in terms of
getting things done on set and I think
relatability is great I mean people want
to be friends and work with your friends
and be cool but I'm not really in the
tone meetings I asked the same questions
I think how do you maintain that
consistency of tone of energy with
different directors you know because
some people aren't necessarily action
directors that they'll do more do a
couple TV shows rather than doing
big-budget you know you're gonna have a
big budget action director typically do
a big budget action film again mm-hmm
yeah so I think attitude I think
suggestions I think differentiate people
from from one another but also I just
think sometimes and also the each
director kind of brings like one will
bring up a cart on the set like a coffee
cart or one which keeps people motivated
keeps the crew pumped and it keeps a
good nice kind of rapport between all
heads involved you know there's I mean
it's gotta be like four hundred people
working on the set in terms of like the
rigging guys the Transpo guys the you
know on one day and I'm like and half of
them you don't even see right so be able
to have be level-headed and it's you
know it's TV stuff I mean some of the
one to say there's there's egos on and
on every end and there's deadlines and
so you got to be able to deal with it
and be on time and be consistent and if
you can't do what I mean eventually
those opportunities wane now out of out
of all my friends that I know you
probably have the squarest jaw yes
really by far you by far this the most
defined jaw no way to tell the
difference today
do you find yourself being typecast as
like the military the jog I like the
military asked like clean-cut
you know Terry hero okay so when you say
JA you mean like this part or like this
part a little bit here okay but also
this corner right here like this right
here your cheekbones to cheekbone you
got those highlight and there's a line
that goes here two kids made fun of me
in brilliant school they said I had a
head like a Pentagon cuz we were
learning shape looks like lose head I
didn't know and I didn't I was like I
just thought I had this blocky head and
like I never I was bummed about it for a
long time I was like you know and then
finally when I grew up and I'm like my
face kind of got out like girls seem to
like like you they would say structured
face or a strong jaw like I don't I
don't know what that really means and I
kind of see it now but but thank you
I believe it I'm sorry typecast enough
for me like you're do you think you've
been kind of typecast as like the
military esque character look Nico I
don't give a [ __ ] man I'm here to play
I'm gonna do my job the best you can
typecast me however you want but I'm I
work my ass off to be as rounded off as
possible in every which way I challenge
myself as an actor I push myself
physically I push myself in terms of
taking risks
I work my tail off to just do the small
things important so if I'm gonna give
someone a great performance even if I'm
not right for it mm-hm but people are
eventually gonna come around and say of
course we see him like this I'm gonna
let people see that for themselves
though I'm not gonna tell them and say
and and kind of be resentful and say I
don't want to do it because of this if
you're good at something or you fit some
role do it to the best of your ability
make the best of it you know it's like
it's funny it's like like let's say like
this there's like the beautiful girl who
comes up here from Des Moines Iowa right
and she's beautiful prettiest girl in
her school and then she becomes an
actress and then she keeps playing the
hot girl or the or the stripper or this
mm-hmm it's the same thing saying like
well I am more than the stripper I don't
want to do that I'm beyond that it's out
of my it's out of my tits I can do two
other things I'm better than just that
and then you don't get a job doing
anything else but you're so you're self
sabotaging
so why not if you're offered a job or if
you're presented an opportunity to
perform in this in a similar category do
that because it's all about for me the
performance within the moments within
that but for me it's beyond money it's
beyond Fame it's any of that like I've
seen all that what I need is those true
moments that affect people on screen and
it doesn't matter if you're a military
it does matter if you're a stripper
doesn't matter if you're a superhero
we're all human and we have those
moments and for me as an artist as an
actor that's what I give a [ __ ] about
like casting if I do you want to put if
I'll say then at some point I'll
basically be like are I'll do I'll do
your military movie the 15th one I've
done if you pay me this much amount of
money yeah and if you want to pay it
that's fine because I can kill it
because it is there gonna be a shortage
of tough guy needing four needing a
tough guy or a military guy I might not
be right for it but hey I'm gonna make
if the shot that the script is good
whatever I'm happy to work I'm happy to
be enacted yeah I love that attitude
Thank You Man yeah I feel I mean it's
too beautiful it's always worth like
stepping back and looking at how lucky
one is to be even close to doing what
you want to be doing I mean you're even
more lucky to be doing what you actually
want to be doing but to even like kind
of get close to it it's already further
than 99% of the people get to and at
least to me it's always refreshing to
see somebody who's like yeah I I see
that and I cherish it and I run with it
with the energy I got I mean I see that
in you that's really cool thank you man
I mean it's an act you can have because
it's just words letters into words on a
page whatever it in role is mm-hmm but
you can take those same words and have
it's done fifty thousand ways by fifty
thousand every guys you can make this
one role incredible and incredibly
memorable by just taking your own way
and giving a [ __ ] enough to make it
different and making it your own now you
lose those those feelings and those
drives when you start to feel you
deserve more and you're better than just
this and I can do more that's all
[ __ ] that's all self grand-grand
izing entitled kind of mentality
thinking you're beyond anything because
because you can make you can lose
yourself in a role for guard list of
what it is I mean it
if you say ex-military that's not one or
two guys like people from all the world
cultures everything have been
ex-military so it's like you know I mean
yeah that's true how do you what do you
do personally that I guess
differentiates you from the rest of the
military faces or whatever that casting
might be like I just do the same thing
every time you have do you have like a
secret that that you employ more than
you found other people or that you've
learned let's get rid of in like a lump
or something no like like a way to
internalize a character or a way to I
don't know you know like a facial tic or
like something that that you found where
you can say okay you know this guy does
this way this guy does it that way but
one thing that I've found is is this
secret works for me it works really well
well I mean I've I've done a lot of
improv which is working on low status
you know what I mean and it's because
high status is easy you can be just the
jerk and whatever all you want sorry can
you clarify high status and low status
so like so an audience loves to see a
transformation from low to high status
so if we're on stage and basically it's
improv so we choose our roles naturally
and you say hey and then you you take
this the shopkeeper the aggressive
shopkeeper and then I'm the aggressive
Flores and then it's too aggressive guys
going after each other that's not
interesting to see mm-hmm they want to
see a low status a high status and then
I'm like the guy okay I'll keep sweeping
the floor I'm sorry I'll just keep going
and then also the trance the
transformation from low status to high
status and then they just weeper go oh
my god what is this a lotto ticket screw
you I'm gone I'm quitting I'm done
they're like oh yeah okay cool you know
people like to see that transformation
so working on low side of stuff and just
working enough to know what angles work
for me what look what things I like from
my performance it's very hard for me to
watch my performance which is kind of
crazy because you know this is what I do
and I'll do it on set and I love it and
then I see it I don't see it it's a
little wacko but but I look at it from a
very diagnostic standpoint in a very in
terms of how what I can do differently
it's just I've never heard that those
terms use the low status high status
thing but yeah yeah that's real I mean
that's the key to like a roll right
there is you have someone low status and
then the transformation to high status
is really where
where the art form is yes and a lot of
guys in my category that I think that
look well first of all a lot of guys my
category British Australian guys that
are international from different
countries for solder no there's just a
kind of lack of this type I guess
because I see a lot of the guys working
in roles that I would love to do they're
from but that's aside the point but I
think just just working and knowing what
I can do I have the tools in the toolbox
to do certain things allows me the
freedom to really lose myself within the
role you know so whereas if I'm because
if I'd be upset if I could play one way
one thing one way and then keep getting
hired
well yeah be frustrating cuz I don't
want to do that again I don't do that
one thing one way again but no I've
worked to really dig to be able to do
that one thing 5060 different ways and
be like I could do like this so I don't
ever see it really I'll do military
movies whatever it's all military expat
stuff I you find those things in it
based on the script based on character
well you can really play with you use
your past you use what you can use but I
think that I have a very natural I'm
people or grab our understanding of me
being former athlete former military
yeah I'm a bigger dude you know I'm not
a huge dude but I'm like still like I
hold myself with a way that is very easy
to go high status so it's interesting
and the transformative aspect I was
saying it's interesting for someone who
looks like me who seems like they'd have
it all together to be very low status
hmm that's interesting because we're
like that's that's not what we expect
you know so the softening the needing of
of that hardness the exterior of the
shell that comes out with that that
comes from being beaten down in this
business hmm you know for years and just
keeping a good perspective about it yeah
that's really really cool it's a
interesting perspective on that like so
when it comes to like your style of
acting you know acting is one of those
things it's like really hard to define I
feel like for a lot of people like does
it make believe like are you just like
when I look sad - I'm just like moving
my face muscles to where they would be
about actually said like or or am I
trying to like get really deep and like
bring up real emotion and like I feel
like acting it can fluctuate from where
all the way on the real side - all the
way on the
lately fabricated I'm just you know
making a fake smoke on the side of
things um where does it lie for he like
what is what is your approach to trying
to portray a scene an interesting but
authentic way like how do you achieve
that you it's funny because yeah acting
is exactly what you don't want to do you
don't want to act you want to get
yourself and load yourself up with
memories with thoughts with everything
that's that's that's parallel with this
character and this how close as you can
get it and just living and being in that
moment just living just being just doing
nothing not acting not indicating
nothing just sitting there and I mean
having thoughts and having thoughts
shout-out to Leslie Khan my awesome
acting teacher it's all about the
thought it's not about the thought of
what I'm going to say it's not about
thought of what you just said and how I
feel about that and living through that
moment the audience will put themselves
into the role into the story hmm the
minute you start acting people go up
well that was exactly
I think he's not being that you know
he's pretending to be that if I'm like
you moms I'm like don't try to cry like
just be sad and if you can't get there
don't be anger but if you I can be sad
on and I got to be sad about so I can do
that and have thoughts but it's not it's
funny because it's so counterintuitive
to say I'm an actor like you go to
acting class to learn how to act but
then when you get to be a connect or
you're not acting yeah you're not
pretending you're just wearing your
audition so now I'm like this is me so
how do you how do you reset when you get
into a role and you're not acting and
you're required to be sad or you're
required to be eccentric it's what do
you go back to to find yourself the gym
has been my anchor for the most part in
terms of really knowing being one on one
with my mind mind in my body which is
one thing but I think you know I just
did a film called dreamcatcher it's
gonna be really cool to thriller and
there's a scene when I have a nice four
minute like I come in the theater and
I'm looking for the guy and I see this
and what is this and a bloody thing here
and I'm like oh my god and then
eventually I did find the killer and
then it was a death scene and I wanted
it to be really good because the guy was
much smaller than me and he was trying
to like suffocate me with this tarp and
I was like
I wouldn't believe that if a guy comes
up to me so I'm gonna knock his ass out
and run away I'm done right so we we
added a little hit of the crowbar to the
head and all that stuff and he wasn't
really like going for it I was like you
know what this one go for it like really
go for it and he did and it was scary
because I took and I knew it was gonna
sell the scene was the inhale and the
bag goes into the mouth and whatever and
I took good three good deep breaths and
it was completely I was suffocating like
I couldn't and then eventually when I
hit the ground I had to pull even though
I was dead I was out of frame but I had
to pull it away from my mouth because I
was like that's how people die and get
suffocated you [ __ ] die and that's it
I'm sorry for cussing that's okay and so
and I was driving along and all of a
sudden this thought came into my mind I
was like to go see someone about this I
was like this did this leave an imprint
or my lung cuz I'm like that's scary
[ __ ] and then the scene I was dead but I
was like that was kind of gnarly
so that was intense resetting is just
really kind of getting back to the work
and kind of just you know doing you can
to kind of just release things
physically and just get out of it but
know that your next drop is not
guaranteed and you really want to be
prepared when you go in for a role and
not just jump ahead because things will
come up that you're not prepared for and
it'll be a disaster so a lot of
breathing exercises yeah I know a lot of
reading I paint painting helps me really
kind of get back down to like when I
just exhale I have a nice much finer
sharp stroke and it's it's good leave a
style of painting yeah it's like I'd say
it's pop surrealist
it's very hard lines colorful very
beautiful ferrigno underscore art on
Instagram is all of it and if you
haven't seen it you actually be like
well it's actually pretty good I'm gonna
check it you know I don't you never
really finished with a piece of work of
art but these are pretty cool and I have
to say I'm like I'm very proud of the
work that I've done but that helps me
really kind of get back down to Ground
Zero yeah well we'll say it like when
you showed me your paintings when I
first met you it was quite a surprise to
see that other side of you because
they're nice paintings thank you minute
yeah they're better now that's good yeah
that's why you asked about the walls
yeah cuz you're thinking eh what would
make it good like you look at a wall and
you see yes
a piece of art on it yeah I think you
guys yeah I mean I'm very perceptive you
know I just like the little things like
I love how you guys have displayed the
DES logo and so many different ways
across the office and and artistically
it's like it's great you know and even
the panel right there the sound panel
turned diagonally beautifully thank you
when you were uh when you're playing a
character mm-hmm and you know you're
putting yourself in this other I guess
person's shoes for potentially weeks and
if not months at a time do you ever find
yourself kind of losing your sense of
who yourself is in that process like
when you're when you're able to make
yourself somebody else on a frequent
basis where that's your profession do
you ever find that like who you are is
just another role that you're just used
to playing you know there's always a
piece of you that comes with to every
character to make it real you know
because if I want to be like woo from
from Venus like this guy that doesn't
work it's not real yeah yeah I mean and
look and the way I book SWAT is there
was like a scene the first scene was it
just said we there's a joke and then a
wing man laughs in parentheses and then
Spiderman so that wing man laugh was a
million different ways to do it and you
could have done all these force
different things but I just did it how
naturally I would do it that I've caught
on to people laughing about when I just
have a genuine response did it like that
book job you know so there has to be a
piece of realism to that now I'll be
honest the work that I've done
professionally hasn't really I mean rush
did it really gave me a chance to really
get into that character because it was a
it was a nice long piece there was a lot
to it and the relationships I think in
terms of how you deal with the
relationship with someone else a lot of
the character can come out and through
that but I haven't really got a lot of
dialogue heavy roles or characters yet
so Rex Tyler should be one of the
biggest ones and there's a lot to that
but I try not to I have to preserve my
sanity as an actor because every day is
insane what we're doing is insane it's
rich doing the same thing over with
what's
doing the same thing over expecting
mm-hmm so if I don't go to class I'm not
getting better and if I'm not getting
better I'm doing the same thing if I go
an audition after audition of the
tradition of doing the same thing and
not booking and wanting to book that's
textbook insane so I try to I try to I
have to keep one foot one foot on planet
Earth before I really try to say I'm
gonna lose myself or I'm gonna go here
I'm gonna go there I know that what what
I buy is real human emotion real human
situations and all that stuff not I'm
gonna show you how great I am in moments
like come on like you know I mean I want
to see being affected more than anything
else one one thing is a moding and
showing how good you are as opposed to
really be letting that ball drop and
being doing just about nothing but
letting that ball drop that to me is
this more fascinating than how much I
can show you or whatever so hmm and a
lot of it is just being calm being
available and being relaxed so and
that's the hard part is really being
calm and relaxed pgf 200 people on set
looking at you on monitors and
everything high stakes and you have to
say these lines when he's doesn't say
and have and be believable and action
and you have to be ready for that yeah
if you've never done it you will I mean
as if you want to be an actor and you
want to do that and get thrown in that
limelight you wolf my guess is you fail
because there's too much to do to make
it seem and be and make it seem
believable and relaxed mm-hmm and be
that you can't act relaxed if you're not
relaxed you know I'm saying are relaxed
so it's fine it's it's funny though it's
like the big part of the job is just
really being relaxed and letting that
channel be open to receive those little
nuances you know you feel like it's
viewed to be relaxed it seems like to
you that means being prepared like more
prepared you are the more relaxed you
are and preparing does that mean just
like you know obviously obviously you
know knowing the lines but beyond that
is it delving into like you know
creating backstory for his character is
it rehearsing like to you what is being
prepared as an actor being prepared is
for me goes way beyond being prepared as
an actor that's I mean that's
job that's I'm supposed to do so yes I'm
gonna have their words down and
everything else that I prepared on a
level of there's so many people on set
and people that want to meet and I'll
talk to I'll research people's names and
I'll see what they've done and the
opportunities to talk with them or even
know who I'm talking with and know what
this person can do and being prepared on
where I can go with an actor or in a
scene and honestly the more prepared I
am the calmer I am because as we started
the podcast I got a little sweaty
because I don't know we're talking about
you know you could ask me some invasive
you know but um so that kind of like
good but those nerves make you alive but
as an actor I know that I'll be
physically prepared and a lot of that
comes with being in shape because when
you're on set and you're working you're
not getting it you know there's no shape
like we have a gym on set but hours are
long it's tough it's it's so hard to you
have to stay healthy it's so there's so
much to it
but beyond just being I know I mean I've
mapped out the Google droughts how much
time I can get there where I can eat it
round there I have food packed with me a
lot of times like I am prepared on many
different levels and then I can just
kind of breathe because I'm like I don't
need to worry about what time craft
services or like cuz I'll be like oh
breakfast orders don't get you one and
then I'll like say a breakfast order and
then I have three and a half seconds to
eat it and then I'm in a van I'm like yo
oh my god this is frazzled I can't like
I have to be prepared for all of that so
I eat before the house I do all that
stuff so there's no surprises mitigate
the damage done by the surprises
essentially yeah so do you find yourself
as part of your craft you find yourself
observing observing others to you know
like the laughs thing you were talking
about sometimes I find myself doing this
when thinking about writing or I'm
thinking about a character that that I'm
trying to create is I'll think back to
moments when I think of other people
doing something or other people saying
something do you I know that's very
important in writing do you find it's
also important and acting to take
experience of observing other people and
applying that to maybe your own roles
yes I think but you have to know that it
works you know like there's actors that
do certain things and you cast in
certain roles because what they do for
that role works so like I have I have a
buddy that is just
funny like just funny how he is but I'm
not funny like the way he's funny
so if I try to do something I thought
was really funny that he did in my way
it doesn't work cuz it I mean if I do it
in my way to work but if I tried to do
it like he does it it doesn't work yeah
you know so I think stage is important
to really kind of work things out and
get an immediate feedback on what works
comedic ly and what works dramatically
in terms of gripping an audience that's
that's a great place to start but I
think but I think it's really just it
has to be true to what you're doing and
who you are the most part but you have
to I mean in terms of observational I my
mind goes every which way
yeah when I when I watch films for
probably the majority of my life halfway
through the movie ninety-five percent of
the time I have no idea what's going on
the movie because I if I don't know
what's going because I'm so in tune to
the moments I've only watching the
moments are they believable if he said
that I'm watching all that yeah so I
don't I'm not looking at plot nice okay
so this is exposition this I don't I've
never seen it like that I've only seen
how real it is at the moments and a half
wait doesn't look like what is this
movie about because I'm like that's real
that's not I don't believe that and I
think that works is me being an actor
but I observe everybody all the time
everything I try to be out of my phone I
try to think it's interesting what's
what makes someone charismatic and what
makes someone interesting and what makes
someone funny and what gravitates
towards us and it's all those little
nuances that people have that are really
a byproduct of just an authentic
reaction you know like just people who
are authentically them I think it's so
cool you know I don't think what's
because what's cool like you'll be cool
what's cool in yourself there's nothing
cooler than just being yourself there's
like look at this jacket this is cool I
don't wear stuff like this but I'm like
I feel pretty cool
you know but I'm like hey this is what I
put together and I'm like that's cool
being like everybody else isn't cool
so I like to learn from other people and
and just pay attention just pay
attention every day because it's my job
is to replicate the human condition and
make it as real and believable as
humanly possible because it affects
people on that certain level yeah
and it's funny because I'll just I'll be
doing it
scene in class and be sitting there take
a breath quiet and it's like absolute
silence and I'm like dear I'm like that
is that's so sexy to me cuz I'm sitting
there and everybody's gripped and I'm
like you know but they know that I
believe it and they're probably like I
don't wanna be in there with them or not
like it's good or it's really awkward at
least they're like you know yes yeah
it's a reaction yes and that to me is
like within that silence is just like a
booming like just this booming echoing
like like Rumble for me that's know like
you know I'm like ah from action to cut
I'm living in the most peaceful time of
my life and it's so awesome because I
will die for those moms I'll die for my
crowd I'll do whatever I need to do to
do this what I do and I don't care if
you like me or not or you think I'm good
or not or whatever doesn't matter from
action to cut I'm in control
yeah we can do it a thousand times but
between action cut I'm the one making
the calls and all you know I mean I've
loved working directors but I think just
think that's fascinating yeah that in
this world everybody set up for those
moments and then some actor can just be
some douche that's like so funny so
crazy
yes world yeah yeah I suppose you are
you are telling the cameras where they
have to point I'm gonna walk over here
you better point the camera at me dude
everything has to be you know and but
people get lost than that people get
lost in the in the idea of Hollywood and
celebrity and it's not that and I think
my father was a bodybuilder first and
then he became this I mean iconic care
figure you know and he's been an actor
ever since but he doesn't have I have
just this I might I exist for this but I
just and I'm okay with was saying that
and BIA
and I in you know I'm not I don't think
I'm your quintessential actor and your
typical actor but that's what makes me
special you know but I just I am seeking
to go further yeah deeper into the truth
how much do you value celebrity
considering that's you know something
that you are close to with your family
like is it something that has really no
meaning to you at this point and it's
not it's insignificant or is it
something where it's just like a part of
the tooth like that one of the tools of
your trade so to speak you know it's
funny it's it's interesting because
if you're if you're good at anything
it'll garner attention mm-hmm you know
whether you want to or not you're being
good at something we'll debt but
celebrity has been so much more
commoditized than and famous a commodity
at this point you know what I mean in
people being famous for just being
famous and reality people and and I like
the reality shows when you're like
learning about let's say the deck with
his catch and you're learning about
these things in life that are great but
it's everything changes when these
people try to do anything else because
like you're not a celebrity like you
don't you're a fisherman or you're like
log in the woods but they're given
celebrity because they're on this TV
show hmm so I but I've seen it from a
real very world-famous admiration level
of several celebrity my father was
genuinely and is genuinely famous like
him really famous people from all over
the planet I'm talking like I was in
Thailand one time and one of the mail
clerk saw my saw my ticket my and he was
like for like okay like yeah I'm I come
across all across the world I'm still
like oh my god
so for me it's different there and
within that I mean my dad loved body
bowling I mean he just loves it more
than anything and that's what so he was
never in it for the fame it happened but
how he dealt with it we were always
around very famous people good people
and not good people but it was
interesting to see and my mother too
like had a very grounded perspective
about what Fame was who we are and who
she wanted her kids to be so for me Fame
I've honestly I've been left living with
a very level of Fame that I didn't do
anything
to procure hmm I just was given this
fame through this name and so I've seen
it and I've seen what it does to people
and I've seen how people react to it and
so a lot of it's interesting and I can
go on and on and on about how people can
change on a dime and pretend to be your
friend or have a litany of ulterior
motives so I'm very I don't want to say
jaded but I'm very conscious of the fact
of what is real and what is not like
last night I had I had to reach out to
my godparents and I was like I need to
just hang out and have dinner
with you you know I'm a single guy I
don't have much to really spit ball with
someone anyone so I was like I just need
to give grounded down to reality I went
to a party and it was a it was a rap
thing and just so Hollywood you know I'm
like I was having a good time and
everyone was very sweet but like you
know there's a peripheral like oh my god
yeah we should you know like like rock
climbing with you was so much fun you
know cuz it was like as we got along and
it was great in Detroit and it was like
real you know I mean and so so it when
it's people just doing real things so I
and that's a definite advantage is I've
been I've been blessed with this glimpse
at what Fame is without having to have
the constant like oh my god like people
be waiting like three deep in
restaurants when I was young to get a
signature an autograph for my dad while
we were at at dinner and there was times
when they're like here I have to I
signed it cuz this is one of my dad's
autograph yeah you know just trying to
be nice and he's just like yo I'm eating
you know you'd be mobbed around the
around the world we go to Amsterdam
there'd be Hameed walking with two other
guys and there'd be about three feet of
space and then just like 50 dudes just
like wall together walking like
following him through the streets like
you know I know we get lost my mom and I
but they don't give a [ __ ] because I'm
just this kit Sarah who I am and they
find our lose kid okay so getting like
surrounded by all these dudes it's just
mopping my dad waiting for pictures
waiting to see him waiting to look at
him you know it's it's like part freak
show part celebrity were like like movie
star like he was crazy it was
interesting so that's another big yes
yeah growing so growing up like in that
environment like there's I mean
everybody has this thing we're like
taking certain things are granted and
you get older and you experience the
rest of the world and like wait every
kid doesn't get to experience this this
is unique to me and you know to you I
was your world you know at a certain
point in general so like what was one
thing that you growing up then once you
reach like kind of age of self-awareness
looked around was like that's very
unique what I got to experience like is
there something it stands out to you
that's like that experience whether it's
you know meeting meeting movie stars in
real life just all the time versus you
know being someone who lives in the
other side the world
they never experienced that or is it
like what are there some like unique
experiences that you can point to or
it's like this is something that I look
back on and really stands out as being a
special thing I mean I think people a
lot like when I was growing up I didn't
know why the people a lot of people a
lot of times were excited to meet me hmm
and I was like I like I haven't done
anything you know like I didn't I'm just
this guy like you know like people be
excited and they had known about my dad
like I don't even know about pumping
iron till I was like eleven twelve like
I'd ever saw it and he would talk about
it and they which is an awesome movie
dude like dad sound but I'm like this is
a dope-ass well done documentary yeah so
that was interesting to see people you
know and I always got like like there
was always chatter behind me because
that my friends were never anybody that
was really expected any famous but then
their friends would meet me and then
they would talk all the time about me
and then it would be funny to hear from
my friends like oh well Lou gets this I
didn't I don't know you know I think
people were and I was also a really big
kid so I was like nobody really ever
like mess with me and Blair but there
was just this it was just it was oh it
was it was always an understanding for
me that people I came with a little side
package in terms of meeting people like
it was never just me so I always had to
think that people weren't really excited
to meet me and to be honest I don't
think that people a lot of people have
the ability to be genuinely connected to
someone and talk with someone and be
real aside from everything living in LA
you know there's always that whole Fame
thing matters to a lot of people you
know I don't give a [ __ ] who you are man
I guess if you're good at what you do
and you're cool person and you're and
you're just an impressive human being
that's all that matters to me I don't
care I've seen Fame I can see what I've
seen what Fame does to people Fame kills
people like it can get to that point
yeah but film is what our famous 100%
man-made
like you just give it you know to like
these people when it's time I guess cuz
these people are famous throughout time
that just are never really seen or heard
from but they just go do great work and
they're adored and then they slip right
out the back door you know what I mean
you don't have to have it but it is a
good kind of it's a it's it's good to
recognize something that's that's good
but it's so convoluted nowadays
do you think do you think as an actor
you need to have followers to book a gig
or can you just be a good actor I'm
stealing Jake's question because I want
to transition that like into looking
forward a little bit
ya know we've talked a lot about where
you come from how you do how you do what
you do but looking forward a little bit
the state of the current industry you've
done a bunch of TV you've done a bunch
of film you have you have a very good
understanding of the traditional
industry and and everything that comes
with it with the rise of the digital
industry as it has been over the last
5-10 years how has that changed what you
do and then is is there I have this
theory that you know people does
followers equal work and this is a
little bit what you were saying about
The Deadliest Catch
sort of thing like people get famous for
a certain reason or they get followers
for a certain reason and then you know
are they getting work because of that or
because they have followers are they
getting work because they're truly
talented or is it is it both so yeah do
you think it's something where in the
future as as the industries continue to
merge and people continue to just put
things on screens do you think that
followers plays a role in for example
you getting work I think that follow I
think if you're good like I said before
if you're good at anything
it will garner attention people will be
like seek it out you know like and my
numbers on IMDB have gone up every time
I'm on SWAT higher if not highest on the
show I don't know why but people
something like what I'm doing I don't
know what it means I think you'll have
followers and a massive following in
that sense I think it's definitely a
plus to have a huge following for
projects that are looking for people
with big followings you know and I think
it's a quicker way to get your way to
the those trolls but the truth is it's
not about booking the roles it's about
it's about I mean its booking the roles
but it's like if you're not good at what
you do you could have a million
followers and your [ __ ] your [ __ ] with a
million followers yeah and eventually
that's gonna be
it's gonna be till it burns out very
quickly and people mature and people
change and interest go an interest wane
and if you're still [ __ ] you're gonna be
[ __ ] with more fault you know I'm sayin
now I think it's and I've worked with a
lot of actors older than me that are
awesome and they have great careers and
they've been working with some of the
biggest names in Hollywood and they
don't even have a social Facebook
they're barely on Facebook but a lot of
times it's more of like they know they
should be doing it and I think I'm lucky
enough to have been around like right
when as it was happening it wasn't
everything but unfortunately I think
it's going to for it's going to present
itself as an alternative to really
really working your ass off on it on
your craft by saying I'd rather if I
just post and do online content and get
the views and viewership up that will
that will justify me not going to class
that will G justify me not going the
extra mile and challenging myself as an
artist as a professional as anything and
I think it is possible to work without
followers I think if you're a model and
you're doing things that are less
particular and to you and if then I
think it's absolutely essential to have
followers and because that's what it is
it's essentially models now can just
control which way they go but after a
while people get sick of a one-trick
pony I don't care who you are if you got
a great ass and that's all you got and
then you spread your ass on Instagram
500 times sweet but then eventually
stuffs gonna go awry yeah and a lot of
times it's gonna start with the person
being like I'm more than just the ass
ready
Instagram mob I want to do opera and
then it's like no you're the asset
reading Instagram model do that or we're
done and then you know so stuff like
that happens because there I'm it's
really interesting human the human
experience that we're on they're all the
same in the sense of us or these bodies
and these the perfect machines that have
chemicals that have hormones that have
everything that kind of work in
conjunction with one another and they
react certain ways if you get sad
there's addictions possibility all this
stuff that can happen that we all go
through a midlife crisis they say it on
purpose everyone goes through that so
you can have a bajillion followers and
work all the time and be absolutely
miserable you know what I mean so it's
an until
you get there you don't know how bad it
is if they have no internal life
anything to talk about
I mean it's it's gonna hurt and
eventually people are going to use that
and you'll be upon yeah I just feel like
that's that's so much in the
conversation now with with talent that
I've seen it's just people are always oh
hey can I put this on my you know
Facebook or can I put this and but
you're right at the end of the day it
comes back to how much you're working on
your talent and your craft and your and
and and doing the work and yeah I think
that's you know I we've always had a
little bit of more of an open I think
perspective when that because a lot of
people look at us from an outside
perspective and go oh you guys are those
influencers you guys are those youtubers
over there in the digital playing in
your little digital sandbox right and
then that's obviously different than
like traditional Union cbs-tv you know
and I think that the mistake that
sometimes people make is not being able
to learn from whatever side of the fence
you're on and and you know not being
able to look over and go oh well there's
a serious show over there where you know
this guy says you know the main thing is
do the work and somebody over here on
our side might say well it's not
important as long as you have followers
and I think yeah just like as as things
continue to grow together which is I
think inevitable with technology and
just the Internet in general I don't
want there to I don't want there to be
this feeling that people in the digital
space aren't aren't learning from from
people in the traditional space because
there's so much history and structure
and wisdom there that if not taking into
consideration like you know what are you
left with you're left with the a
spreading Instagram you know yeah it's
it's just it's just vanity at that point
you know I mean as as as actors like
life happens and you have to grow with
who you are and you have to adjust for
that and live a normal lifestyle like a
lot I just live normal lifestyles and do
random things that you would be
surprised they're not all shop
on Rodeo and lying Pucci and Fendi and
getting on TMZ it's like it's so
unnecessary but people think oh you're
you're being talked about
that's all it matters because at the end
of the day like I mean like Tarantino
doesn't even allow phones on set you
know I mean like that's where I want to
go I want to go working big directors on
big projects and right now all of my
startled stuff is NDA so and it's a big
ass show and it's gonna be big and the
suit that I've been fitting me for is
completely custom every single piece to
my song you've gone to 13 fittings for
it's been about seven fittings okay so
almost but and then ten including the
life cast and everything and it's so
specific everything and I can't put
anything on probably until the show airs
which is in August see I'm cool you have
to stay the same size right now yeah I
mean I'm naturals I'm all-natural
okay I'm so it's like for me it's when
guys fluctuate and get really big and
then all of a sudden like and then get
small everything that's when the drugs
and all that stuff come in yeah but that
all messes with you hired but me no I
mean if anything I'm just gonna cut down
because my whole thing now is this I
used to think it was all about hey I can
look good on screen and be ripped no no
people aren't buying selling by me
because I'm ripped but if I because of
this jaw the Pentagon face button life's
all about man yeah
and it's funny and it's like beyond that
what happens even what the most
important part of that is really just
eating clean and just being consistent
with cardio and stuff like very light
easy stuff there's not a lot of heavy
lifting it's just it's like lifting
everyday you know yeah literally yeah a
little bit of attention but uh you know
Christian Bale changes like physicality
for a lot of his roles do you think he's
using you know steroids and stuff like
that to get so much muscle mass so
quickly or is he just you think really
disciplined and now what are we taught
the biggest one was Batman yeah he
ripped up for a Batman but you know
there's equilibrium way back in the day
and he slimmed down from machinist Mark
Wahlberg do ya he's not that tall but I
there's times when I've seen more
Wahlberg and I said he could be taking
some type of anabolic but I think the
Christian Bale see if you still if you
really put physique side by side well
really the determining factor is how
hard the muscle is like
it's like Heart and Vascular unnaturally
where you're like like if you can't be
that ripped and that big at the same
time without having some type of help
because when you lose all the weight and
get ripped up you lose muscle mass with
it naturally unless you have some
hormonal assistance hmm um anabolics but
I don't think Christian because if you
start having these like super if I had
super shredded low abs and I was 230 and
I was jacked I mean I'm not cold in that
size that ripped like that thank you
because not only do the muscles in your
body and everything like increased but
the muscles in your face increase mmm
and you look like a different human
being
hmm like it changes how you look for
that time that using it so if you really
put down how hard his his physique was
in Batam against it wasn't really he was
kind of puffy but when it comes down to
losing weight and stuff I mean Matthew
McConaughey was one thing for da spires
but when he did The Machinist I can't I
don't even understand how he I mean cuz
he was he looked just like week the week
of death yeah it looks like a Holocaust
survivor yeah and I think he ate just
one like a patty a hamburger day or
Stephanie not at all but like that is a
big big-time risk and really when it
comes to using drugs it's a matter of
putting on muscle mm-hmm as people say I
have a lifetime of muscle I play college
football this has been a part of my life
and since day one so I have a whole
lifetime of muscle built on me so it's
for me to get any bigger would make no
sense then I'd be like you know just
like you went to SC yeah
and you played couple you played ball
there um I wouldn't say play but I I
walked on I hurt got busted my knee up I
made the squad and I busted my knee up
midway through spring practice and then
things happened and then I I was
actually released because of my injury I
had a blown ACL MCL knee was destroyed
it was 230 running for six and then but
it was a classic story like I went the
year before and I went to practice and I
went to be Carroll and I was like my
name is Lou Ferrigno jr. I'm gonna meet
you I'm gonna be worth playing for your
next season and he was like I just I
just knew it I just knew it and so they
released me and then the next day he
personally called me in he's like I want
to be a part of this team and I was like
yeah but I can't do anything I'm on my
knees Blancas it doesn't matter how do
we know what you're capable of and we
could see it and I'm watching be part of
this team and this and it's awesome so I
got to spend a year with the squad I
mean I spent a year and a half training
like on my own I worked with some
trainers just to be to really push
myself and achieve that and get to that
level but in terms of playing no I was
actually injured and that was the end of
my career hmm but I was I want to go to
college you graduate from college but I
always wanted to be an actor so that was
always kind of where I was gonna go and
I thought football like I wanted to
cross that off and be like I I could
have played with the best of the best
and the truth is that could I had the
physical ability at that time in terms
of my capability athletically to hang
with the best in the country these guys
were all on full rides they were top one
program they lost to Texas two year
before in the national championship I
mean top program and we ended up winning
six straight Rose Bowls and they kept me
on as a walk-on because of of what I
showed and tryout hmm I was there I was
at Notre Dame during that during that
time oh yeah yeah that's how Jake isn't
like SC any more school okay yeah still
be friends okay it's just good to know
that you weren't on the field during the
Bush bush no no what I was trying to vet
out there we would had this conversation
which was an illegal move it was at the
time you can do it now what is the push
push so okay so just probably remember
it yeah for those member it like it was
yesterday
for those of you who don't know Notre
Dame used to play plays it plays SC
every year and it's a big college
football rivalry and this was when you
know you guys were running all these
national championships and SC was by a
mile the best team in college football
they were like no Alabama is today wait
except Alabama just lost they do I mean
but there anyway yeah yeah yeah they're
they're one of the best and so yeah
huge game SC was undefeated it was a
Notre Dame chance to take him out we had
the lead
they drove down the field and the with
like a minute to go in the fourth
quarter and it was this whole Drive I
won't get into that but the the final
play of the drive got like called back
and then they they were they ran it
again and then when they ran it again
because we stopped him the first time
and then they ran it again and Matt
Leinart got behind Reggie Bush and later
Leinart was was trying to reach and he
was stalled there was nothing that's
right yeah yeah he wasn't going anywhere
and Bush came up behind him and pushed
him pushed him into the end zone is
basically like a rugby scrum which was
illegal at the time and they didn't call
it and it caused SC to win the game and
it was man we were cheering we had we
thought we'd won the game everybody was
going nuts
I was I was at my buddy's apartment like
a half-mile from the stadium and you
could hear the stadium in just from how
loud it was outside at his place it was
like a rock concert it was crazy and
then we thought we want everyone started
going nuts and then they slowed the
whistle and they're like now I'm gonna
redo it yeah see that look see the
feeling he's having right now that I
take note of and that he's affected by
so when a story comes up that's real
okay we got to the we got to the college
football playoff this year so yeah well
Dana kid names good comeback yeah joint
conference but it's all right no yeah no
no never much money to be made outside
of one yeah so football was you know I
just want and I'm glad I did it
although but you know I blew any CEO but
I could have been like oh my life was
[ __ ] why me
right but I went through rehab physical
rehab for six months and I learned so
much about recovery and so much about
discipline and so much of building the
hard work is because I had another
teammate who tore his ACL a week after
me and three months later I had done all
the work cuz those first two weeks this
first month
is really like critical for really
building the strength and to support the
knee and this dude who come over all the
time and play video games never show up
to rehab to schedule rehab and you never
do it and then when it was time to get
back on the field he was out made a
couple moves and then one day he just
did this tort retort mmm that's it right
back into it yeah I'm like damn that's
reach air it - that's it's bad it's a
devastating injury you know it's a
little rubber band and that's controls
everything
lateral it sucks so stuff like that so I
I've tried to take it as you know you
got to make chicken salad at a chicken
[ __ ] or so they say I heard that I
haven't heard it like that do you still
feel that to this day like what your
your ACL well what I did my left one in
high school and then my right one in
college so now it's like they're even
but no I mean I had great doctors on
both and I you know I'm very I'm very I
don't want to say I'm on like I'm like
when we were doing the one-wheel mm-hmm
I know it's like to really be in pain
and to really have a devastating setback
mmm twice so that's not happening again
and I'm gonna do everything I can to
prevent that so if it's at the cost of
me not playing not whooping with the
boys or not hopping on the one wheel and
trying a trick mm-hmm I'm okay with that
at this point of my life the risk reward
I'm completely fine and it's um not
having to do that
you learn though it's wisdom mm-hmm but
in terms of physical performance
capability if I hadn't had them done I'd
be probably crippled by like I would
every I'd give out like you there's
times in your you would step and then it
would just give out that now when I step
it's secure I'm like well I remember
when it wasn't like that yeah but you
have to get the surgery you have to do
the rehab and you have to get back on
your feet to have it work but when it
gets cold it's a little stiff but no man
I mean like I'm I'm going through life
pretty good I feel like I'm I'm aging
with some dignity you know what I'm
saying I feel like I'm I'm treating
myself in a healthy way I'm I'm trying
to be kind of roll with the punches as
life comes almost complains about how
they look and on this stuff it's like
just have a great perspective and
attitude and posture really are the two
kind of indicators of like that will be
I'll be out in terms of feeling young
looking young you know yeah it's good
stuff so yeah and no one takes as three
white guys a 23 year old white guy
nobody takes you seriously like no I
didn't I wasn't taken seriously for a
long time and then like you know just
you just trouble the goin wants you know
now if I dress like this people like I
walk out and I'm like a mature guy and
people are like oh my god okay hi how
are you on nicely to me now you know
yeah it wasn't like and I was ready to
fight at any moment like like just like
injustice everywhere like you know I
mean and now it's just like it just goes
with life but I mean I definitely like
taking a hard like general meetings and
pitch meetings and stuff we had back mmm
when I was 20 20 30 here like nothing
would ever come of it
like no one's gonna give you a budget to
shoot a film when you're a 25 year old
kid you know so you're praying for like
every gray hair and your beard you know
this guy's been around but that's how it
goes to it you know from as a twenty
four or five year old actor like it was
almost like let's see how how this turns
out not really we can handle it we can
give this guy you know like a film like
you know I'm saying so but you got to
stick through those tough times and
that's what makes the perseverance is
what makes builds character yeah
definitely so yeah well ooh thank you so
much for joining us this has been so
great yeah it was really cool I loved
all the perspective you had on things i
some can't build a chicken salad with
chicken [ __ ] or whatever that's right
gonna make a chicken salad from chicken
[ __ ] yeah like that I'm saying yeah yeah
you're very inspiring guy and I think
that your your work ethic and your
discipline comes through and I think
that that shows not only you as a talent
and and in your career but just in life
and I think a lot of people can take
inspiration take that home from this
thanks for sharing that way yeah is
there anything you want you want people
listening to this podcast to check out
of yours any swap yeah all right so we
got SWAT Thursday 10:00 p.m. I'll be on
this week in the next few weeks a lot of
good stuff coming up 911s coming up in
March 3 its revamping I'll be on the
episode 212 chimney
begins it's awesome it's been well
received and then look out for star girl
coming out in around August and at
Laphroaig no joke calm Lou Ferrigno jr.
on all platforms how can they find star
girl when that comes star go we'll be on
The WB DC streaming platform but in
October we'll go to Netflix cool so
it'll be out star girl it's gonna be
awesome
sweet thanks Lou yes thank you so much
greater conversation all right well that
was a great podcast go check out Lou's
Instagram and his art it's good stuff
tell him he was a cool guest asking cool
questions at Lou Ferrigno junior and
guys you may have heard this at the
beginning but I'm gonna remind you one
more time this podcast is brought to you
by our new merch that's right I got a
cozy sweatshirt on you can see it if
you're watching this on youtube it's
great it's cool iridescent corridor logo
on the front and it's really warm
because it's really cold out right now
and I I'm not supposed to be wearing
this right now beyond just showing it
off but I've been wearing it all day
except cold so I stole the sample the
one sample we have to wear and it's
great I'm loving every second of it so
they are this Nellie's this sweatshirt
in store but we brought back some old
designs that people loved they are gonna
go fast because we have a limited stock
so if you want them head on over to
corridor digital dot store that's right
it's corridor digital dot store alright
guys I'll see y'all later subscribe to
the YouTube channel if you haven't and
find us anywhere else that you listen to
podcast if you want to check us out and
Spotify or iTunes or what have you
alright guys I hope you enjoyed it catch
you on the next one